basically there's two points i'd like to
make today so the first to suggest uh
some people have critiqued the human in
the loop as simply being a way to
scapegoat human operators the failure of
systems which beyond their capacity to
control
i think these critiques simultaneously
enshrine an overly conservative or
restrictive conception of the function
of the human in the loop
in a way which alights the human in the
loop's capacity for creative
interpretation and intervention in the
use of even complex technologies in the
workplace or within automated systems
so i argue
i argue nothing because my slides aren't
working
[Music]
that would be the problem
because it's the same as the first slide
great good all right
thank you
um okay so i owe you the inadequacy of
the human in the loop what i would
describe as its anachronistic nature is
also the condition of its
necessity and its possibility
specifically argue that the human loop
has not become an anachronism but it is
born as an anachronism it's always too
late always too much after the fact but
the fact of it being after the fact
compels it always to reinterpret its
situation and to produce a situation
anew and this is a kind of interpretive
creativity which i think can't be
automated and which as such remains the
necessity of the human in the loop
second point i'd like to make is to
sketch out a genealogy of the human in
the loop the human factor the human
operator
beyond the better known anglo-american
tradition and namely within the french
the francophone tradition of work
studies and i'd like to point to
particularly two factors which have been
influential in the french work science
tradition one is the insistence upon
understanding the milieu of the
workplace and its specificity
and within a broader social conception
of struggle and antagonism an antagonism
which expresses itself in complex ways
but which is important to bear in mind
because as especially veronica kaiser
argues is only ultimately able to be
taken care of by workers themselves
the second key contribution is the
emphasis in french work studies on what
borrowing from the language of
linguistics is termed catacresis
catechresis in the linguist linguistic
tradition refers to the use of an
incorrect word to describe something you
lack the right term for so in french you
call a potato a ponder tear like an
apple from the earth you know obviously
a potato is not an apple from the earth
right
so in french work studies though
catechesis is used catechistically to
describe at one level the wrong use of
tools in the work environment when a
given environment is found to lack the
right tools for the job
but also more suggestively the creative
capacity of error the capacity to
reinterpret the meaning of work itself
and of one's role beyond or at any rate
differently to the ostensibly proper
definition of that role and this kind of
error i also don't think can be
automated and so remains the ironically
proper improper role of the human in the
loop
now the figure of the human in the loop
has been proposed as a safeguard against
the dangers of ai and automation but its
inadequacy has been much commented upon
including by some of my learned friends
in this seminar
one of the most forceful thoughtful and
influential critiques though has been
that of madeline ellis and her argument
regarding a human in the loop as a moral
crumple zone so ellis traces genealogy
of the human the loop and human factors
theory arguing the human operator is
often born the brunt of blame in a way
which distracts from our understanding
of broader socio-technical context of
accidents and other harms and alice uses
the term moral crumple zone describe the
way the human loop becomes quote more
than just the articulation of the
scapegoat
term is meant to call attention to the
ways in which automated and autonomous
systems deflect responsibility in unique
and structural ways protecting the
integrity of the technological system at
the expense of the nearest human
operator and this is a thoughtful and
welcome critique and one which elish
supports through a careful genealogical
genealogical account of the concept and
particularly through an analysis of the
three-mile island accident
the 1979 three-mile island accident
marked an important inflection point in
the development and regulation of
automated work systems investigations
into the partial meltdown of reactor
number two at the three mile island
nuclear power plant emphasize the
significance of control room operator
errors in the unfolding of the accident
the failure in the control room to
respond adequately to cascading alarms
and ambiguous indicator lights was taken
by many as indicating a need to quote
eliminate human operators from such
systems as a way of eliminating human
errors and enhancing system safety as
one investigator put it
ellis argues that the way the accident
was covered in the news media and in
official federal investigations blame
place the blame for the accident
unfairly on the human operator in a way
which distracted from the responsibility
of designers and policy makers producing
inherently dangerous socio-technical
systems like nuclear power plants and
that this is colored the way that the
human in the loop is framed even today
she writes cultural perceptions of fault
in automated and robotic systems may
permeate formal frameworks of
accountability through both media
accounts and official accident reports
these perceptions influence the outcome
of legal interpretations of new
technology
now my concern though is that in
articulating the human in the loop as a
moral crumple zone as that which
crumples we reified too much the
assumptions of normative military
cybernetic models of the human operator
or human in the loop
ellish's concern is with the cultural
legacy particularly of three mile island
and certainly the official government
accounts thereof have contributed to
this and the associated news coverage
but i would argue that the most
influential and perhaps enduring
american cultural account of three mile
island was not the telling of the event
in and of itself but rather the hugely
successful creative non-fiction of
thomas wolff's book the right stuff
which came out several months after
three mile island and became an enormous
bestseller selling several million
copies and eventually being made into
the eponymous film in 1983. now the
right stuff isn't about three mile
island but it's essentially a history of
american human factors
which is the interpretive frame that was
used to define and understand through my
island
wolff's book is about how the daredevil
recklessness of american navy test pilot
culture came to define the definition of
what made for the right stuff in the
human operator as understood through the
formation of that most american 20th
century heroes the astronauts who
embraced the dangerous challenge of the
gemini mercury and apollo space programs
the curious thing about this history
though is that wolf's thesis is
essentially that the right stuff that
which defines the normative function of
the human operator is exactly the
effacement of human factors altogether
wolf saw the key quality of test pilots
and astronauts as being essentially a
finely calibrated death drive and he
positions his analysis explicitly
against the effete european anti-war
tradition of remark and his new world
acolytes like ford maddox ford wolf
seeks to redress this anti-war tendency
and for him the right stuff became the
story of why men were willing willing
delighted to take on such odds in this
an era literary people had long since
characterized as the age of the
anti-hero
the spirit of the test pilot and the
astronaut program is incarnated in the
spirit of the eagerness to shut up and
die like an aviator and this is what the
right stuff or courage amounts to for
wolf
now wolf's literary historiography is of
course exceptionally one-sided just as
influential as remark if actually more
influential for its political impact
upon german conservatism was the work of
ernst younga and his theorization of
total mobilization who's great his
tragic celebration of the catholic
elemental experience of war defined the
battlefield as a privileged site for the
experience of the uselessness of
modernity and younger's work i think
provides a prefiguration of wolf's own
much more boyzone dollar store kerouac
account
younger's conservative understanding of
the significance of martial experience
had an immense influence on heidegger
and in turn on friedrich hitler and
kittler's martial determining
determinism has in turn had an immense
impact on the way much materialist media
history is conducted including i think
the work of peter gallison's ontology of
the enemy who famously argued that to
understand the specific cultural meaning
of cybernetic devices is necessarily to
track them back to the wartime vision of
the pilot as server mechanism now we do
certainly see the term human in the loop
first emerge in the early years of
nasa's space program and it's obviously
a borrowing from the military cybernetic
concept of the man in the middle of the
cybernetic modeling of the human
operator as a gunner or pilot as an
element within a military server
mechanism
the problem though i think in such
cultural imaginaries of the cybernetic
human operator and its legacies is that
there's a tight coupling between the
progressive critique of the human in the
loop as both not culpable as well as the
conservative militarist critique of the
human in the loop is not capable
both accounts is a kind of helplessness
the human operator faces when confronted
with the immensity of modern complex
socio-technical systems and this
immensity is irreconcilable with the
scale of human phenomenological capacity
and so must be sublimated either in
death or within the experience of the
kind of blameless culpability that ellis
describes
what's remarkable though is to consider
how the human in the loop is born as an
anachronism as military researcher and
nasa engineer joseph saunders put it as
the weakest link in the weapon system
what is an anachronism george
uh he draws attention to the creativity
of anachronism that which exists out of
time demands an explanation why is it
still here what is it doing here what is
it which has survived of the human
and huberman invokes the freudian idea
of afterwardsness the compulsion to
reinterpret the after the factedness of
traumatic experience in particular but
also of experience in general the point
here is to insist upon the normative
function of reinterpretation
as fundamental to the production of
meaning and to argue that when this
capacity is blocked or suppressed it is
not merely critical accounts which
become impossible but strictly speaking
any account at all
a human in the loop is an anachronism
but it's one which demands an
explanation as well as being the one who
must account for this explanation
now i'm running out of time
but i think it's possible to trace the
genealogy of the human in the loop in a
way which points to its a gentive
capacity it's capacity for
responsibility in a socially situated
and interventionist and creative way and
not merely in terms of culpability or as
that which crumbles
particularly i think there's a tradition
in francophone work studies which takes
up and transforms sort of uh american
human factors research
by emphasizing one the workplace as a
site of social antagonism but also this
idea of catacresis
um
catechesis
in eve closed definition
uh
is what happens when you lack the
vocabulary to define certain ideas so a
characteristic situation is one where a
tool serves a usage beyond its own when
a machine works beyond the limits of its
normal function and it's an index of the
fact that users in spite of everything
contribute to the conception of the
usage of the technical artifact
in this activity rights there is as well
an activity of reconception
so catechresis describes not simply
adaptability and not an understanding of
error as the magnitude of difference
between a prediction and the true value
of an observation but a kind of creative
and necessary error not simply or solely
deviation from a real use but a
deviation from the norm which creates
new norms and new possibilities for
interpretation and reinterpretation or
reconception
um
the kaiser i'm
concluding now um veronique de kaiser
argued that it is precisely the human
operator for whom the question of risk
and responsibility is most fraught who
has the most at stake namely their lives
or their mental physical health who must
be allowed the interpretive capacity to
intervene in defining their own role
within the workplace and that the
evaluation of the workplace environment
is a process which is quote continuous
and collective and conducted by workers
one in which the scientific criteria is
replaced or doubled by a collective
verification
so the implications of these arguments i
think that when we're defining the role
of the human in the loop we must
understand this role in terms of
maximizing what the kaiser drawing from
uh simondon refers to as the zone of
autonomy the capacity and the freedom to
reinterpret and redescribe the meaning
of industrial or automated systems the
human in the loop must have the freedom
to reinterpret and this capacity i think
uh is as much the competit is as much
the outcome of like
workplace protections worker
organization
as of any sort of particular protocol
for making the correct interpretation
so the point here is is sort of to point
to an alternate conceptualization of the
human in the loop in which the question
of culpability seeds ground to the
capacity for capability but also for
reinterpretation intervention and
workplace solidarity and that these
should be sort of considered as key to
the definition of the role of the human
in the loop
today as well i think
so yeah there we go that's it
[Applause]
yes um we have about 15 20 minutes for q
a so
let's welcome the two speakers
and we will collect some questions
that's right
um yeah thank you for both of those uh
excellent papers um i suppose this is a
kind of
response to the request for um options
and um then maybe it feeds into a
question for chris
um
yeah a lot to sing through so i mean
when i was preparing my talk earlier i
kind of wanted to give this example but
um took it out for reasons of time but
um
an interesting example from the stuff
that i researched where the human has
kind of got a particular function
but also serves as sort of as a risk
factor is in the way the european court
of human rights has
passed the issue of what's called bulk
interception of communications right for
intelligence purposes um for crime
fighting purposes
um so basically you know in the
aftermath of the snowden revolutions it
transpires that there's this huge
apparatus for real-time interception and
analysis of data and a lot of the way in
which that data is parsed is done
automatically but
what
the difference makes a difference as it
were to the intelligence agents um
it takes more of a kind of a string of
selector terms that have to be input
into the interface and then they sort of
try to find things that are related to
that
and um
european origin rice has really wrestled
with what this means in terms of mass
you know surveillance and political
power and privacy and all the rest of it
where to find a sort of balance between
that
but it's really
kind of slightly weird
just
in one of the most recent decision on it
the big decisions that have been made um
the big brother watch um in the grand
chamber
the european court funded the british
oversight system which is being kind of
very heavily specified and over kind of
over determined that has this one little
lacuna which is the point at which an
intelligence operator puts in the terms
for searching the system will only
perform and those selections have got to
be themselves justified by reference to
the values of proportionality and that
that's a kind of assessment that i think
like it's pretty much automatic already
right because the terms are already
given so the way these things are
already audited is that they're done on
a kind of they're they're audited by
machine learning processes they're
looking for like is there originality in
each entry or are they copying and
pasting so it's already kind of a
machining kind of process
um and so that's an example um where the
human is the kind of
risk factor but also performs a certain
legal um
you know
normative sort of role
and then i guess that you know for chris
i mean i guess the question simply mean
your presentation is brilliant but like
is this really work already rooted in
the kind of concern for workers um which
puts it antagonistically in relation to
capital maybe it doesn't make the same
sense if you think about it in relation
to say like how the government
aims to control and survey population
a lot to digest
that's a great example though i
appreciate it
i don't know
would be my response
i don't know i mean it depends i mean
i'm not like another law scholar you
know and i'm not an expert in um
you know european governance mechanisms
[Music]
well sorry maybe
i i sorry
yeah i don't know
i would talk about it a while later
um
thanks so i wanted to uh respond to
chris's talk sorry ben if you could sort
of just so i can
um as one of the folks who have been
critical of the human and the loot
paradigm so sort of just want to draw
out some of more of your thinking on
this and then perhaps we should also
have a longer conversation later
um
but i guess two two points i'd love to
hear your thoughts i mean one it sort of
sounded like
at times you were positioning you know
the critiques of the human in the loop
as calling for
uh
just saying get rid of the human in the
loop and let the system go on
otherwise without that human which i
would say is not how most of those
critiques would go so i'm sort of you
know how do you see what the critiques
are calling for as an alternative and
sort of what would you call for as the
alternative sort of given those
limitations of human and the loop that
it goes beyond just saying get rid of
the human overseer because they fall
short
but then i sort of the other piece to
maybe
you sort of have this binary between
culpability and capability and sort of
shifting between them and i would say
you know potentially that's not a binary
my my particular stance on it would be
that actually the problem is both
that we do have the sort of elish style
culpability issues but we also have
capability issues that actually the
types of capabilities you're calling for
even if we do design more in that
direction than for pure scapegoating
are actually very hard to achieve in
practice um so sort of just curious how
you think about
those dimensions of the human and the
loop problem yes no i should i mean but
you know i was sorry
my point is uh certainly not to consider
culpability and capabilities as binaries
or as as a dialectic you know the point
is they are very close you know and they
have to be taken up as
the the they're
you know yes part of the same problem i
completely agree you know
this is sort of part of the thing you
know the kind of i guess the
i'm also not i mean i think elisha's
work is brilliant you know and i think
that account is probably the best
critique i've seen of it you know i mean
there's very good critiques of it
um
the point is you know to kind of like
coming back to this question of
contingency which seems to be kind of
uh
keep returning to you know
um
today
you know is the kind of like openness of
that contingency you know
it's not
the question is like if you sort of
consider politics as like the kind of
like question of the distribution of the
sensible right you know it's the
question of intention you know what is
it that you kind of take as the thing
you emphasize you know
you you know within a legal framework it
makes sense to kind of focus on problems
of culpability you know because
it's a question of responsibility within
a particular kind of uh
particular sort of legal epistemology
you know
but um
i guess my point
is
the point of contingency is there's an
absence or a lack at the at the kind of
um within the definition of any kind of
epistemological system and that's
there's a kind of openness there
and if it's not the kind of human
operator which is able to take
that
sense of culpability
then
who would
you know i can think of i mean it would
have been better if i could have there's
examples i could draw upon here you know
there's in australia for example we had
the debt scandal i don't know if you
know about this
where there was a sort of an appalling
automated
[Music]
recalculation of social benefits and it
was disastrous you know it wasn't a
particularly sophisticated model
it's estimated that several thousand
people died
from suicide you know as a result of the
stress so in terms of an industrial
accident it would be one of australia's
largest industrial accidents ever right
the point is you know here it's not
you have to consider the the it's not
simply the kind of uh uh
unforeseen outcome of a kind of badly
designed system you know it's it's that
operation is situated within a
particular force of
uh a political contingency and there's
sort of stories coming out there's
hopefully going to be a proper royal
commission into rubber dead but the
story is already coming everybody in the
department knew what it was doing it was
quite plainly obvious to the humans in
the loop but they couldn't
rin what i what i'm calling
reinterpretation in a broad sense they
didn't have the freedom
to describe it as a bad system and to
you know to be whistleblowers for fear
of losing their jobs essentially right
or for facing legal punishments right
now the point i'm not arguing that they
are morally culpable in the same way
that like the conservative politicians
who or the designers are
but my point is they were really the
only ones well them and the actual
people who there was a obviously a
social uh solid movement that organized
against it in the end right
i think we have like five or six
[Music]
questions so i'll just collect all the
questions all that was after we finish
the answer and the wall then they come
back to you no no yeah they're about the
internet that's right
but um
uh
so this is the thing it's it's not a
particular i
understand it's a very you know in terms
of defining even the legal frameworks is
very
complicated in the actual
uh whatever the quotation the day-to-day
operation of these things
but this is the problem contingency is
dangerous you know and you kind of have
to i think the human in the loop is the
figure who can like encounter
that thing
not in the kind of death desiring way
that younger celebrates but in a
positive so i think there's a
possibility there
for solidarity social
organization and so forth you know i
think that has to be more
you know that's the argument
okay i i mean my
question was sort of broadly for chris
as well but i feel like there's probably
people who have questions for jd which
maybe we need to hear about as well so
i'm happy to to come
uh yeah this question was for for jd uh
but it it it plays on this like this
discussion of culpability and capability
we've been having since you mentioned
capabilities which is
these llms um and i was thinking like
when we we think about the relationship
between
how how scale might result in new forms
of culpability as well you mentioned the
what a thousand flowers bloom approach
i would just be curious to hear more
about your thoughts on that emerging the
possibility of that
like
expansion of access to these sorts of
systems because off the top of my head
in my networks with like you know my ai
you know friends and whatnot there was a
lot of like solidarity and just sort of
meme formation around like playing with
dolly two
you know outputs and like having him do
like some really offensive [ __ ] that
that's funny and interesting but like
problematic for all sorts of reasons
um but there was a lot of energy on
twitter for like my twitter for two
weeks was just taken up with all these
meetings from from that system so i
would just be curious to hear your
thoughts on
um on those things
netflix
yeah this is
starts out as a question for jd and then
i think it also has a human in the loop
implication and i'm much struck by your
concept of let me see labor of love
and i you know have my favorite example
of um
if i knew that the birthday card i
received from my spouse was
generated with like a lot of help from
llm
um despite the fact that it's probably
you know better
formulated and it's going to come on the
right day and all of those things
i'm not going to see this as a labor of
life
and it kind of gets to this thing of
human in the loop which is in that
instance we really
the human in that loop is quit is
absolutely essential
so it it kind of begs and i i don't
think i've ever had this thought before
with human in the loop and man in the
middle whatever it is which is
any large any any model any
machine learning model
and it has come up in our cluster
discussions involve humans because you
know the training data is
based on human practice human speech
human so like machine learning people
are just we've got it you know lots of
humans in this loop
yeah so anyway
yeah
uh thanks i had a good question um
kind of for both but i appreciate it's
not answerable in the time allowed but
still maybe something to think about so
time i like the temporal element and i
think it's really important we haven't
talked about it very much at all but of
course french philosopher bernard
ziegler
defines the production of historical
time through technology and technicity
that's how we get it
and so what occurred to me here was that
there's sort of a really interesting
thing going on with with temporality
first of all jd
do you know grammarly do you know what
grammarly is so is that what you're
talking about because i
had a visceral reaction to
grammarly as a trained linguist i said
well this is kind of a disaster we're
going to freeze
language production in this loop of
recommendations for how to finish my
sentence and this is going to ossify or
it's going to do something
to a language process that i personally
hate and hate anyone who uses it as well
no
no but i mean i'm serious right so do
you agree that there's a kind of this
risk of ossifying or freezing
cultural life through these
through these products
and i mean i guess more for chris as
well i mean so my critique of humanity
in the paper um
it would be something like
it's precisely through this frozen
anachronism of what this frozen
narrative or imaginary about what what
is happening in decision making
that this anachronism arises i agree
with your analysis i think it's
important
um as a diagnostic of the sort of
arrangement of the necessity and
structure of that thing but i just
it's another version of this political
problem but i guess i come at it from
quite a different angle so i think maybe
we could talk about that another time
okay well i think your first
questionable is answer first question is
answerable in the time we have remaining
and that is yes
[Music]
i think jake
should get
[Music]
so
chris you know that i
have this idea that um
for instance article 22's prohibition on
a fully automated decision or constraint
on a fully automated decision what's
often taken to be
sort of a paradigmatic
human in the loop uh legal provision
uh i i have argued has its roots in
european industrial democracy
um
has its roots in
workers movements to have a say with
respect to the operation of the factory
system
and um
i was like very interested to hear
the reframing of that in the context in
a different work context
where um the human is the
uh
like the
the operator
capable of
i mean
i'm just trying to like resolve for
myself
the subject position of the human in
these two
different accounts and whether they are
maybe the same or whether they're like i
don't know you read that paper of mine
yeah yeah
it's great
that's that's just
i mean the problem that i mean we've
talked about this before right is the
question
too does it it's not like
i'm pointing here
you know
just disappointing the project of
genealogy you know is like it's like
exploding
you know
his the subject of history right you
know so it's just pointing to saying
there's one way
american anglo and even anglo-american
accounts of the um we're very complex
you know i'm wildly over you know
making things too simple
but um
so just pointing to this kind of
different conception and different
tradition the point is of course not
that you can just simply take like what
the french are doing in the 70s and say
like this is the normative model you
know because exactly as
we've talked about this before the works
uh work council tradition in europe is
itself historically contingent right
it's come out of a particular kind of
historical juncture
there's you know and we've
in its which is not operative in america
not operative in australia there's a
similar there's an interesting kind of
like example in the 90s that we've also
talked about
um of kind of early forms of automation
of warehouse systems which led to like
this kind of proto-amazon thing
that led to an enormous industrial
unrest and very interesting legislation
which was brought in kind of modeled
maybe not modeled but something like the
european tradition
um demanding you know like worker
contribution to the definition of kpis
and so forth
they're collapsed because like the
political structure's not there for it
right
so uh
so i don't know i mean i don't think uh
uh
i don't think these are mutually
incompatible but the point is
you know i'm kind of like challenging
say like gallison for example he's
arguing any conception of cybernetics in
he talks in french theory as well has to
be traced back to this like very
particular kind of military cybernetic
model and i said you know in my opinion
this is you know it's like this is like
the normative kind of mythological claim
is that no the human in the loop is
itself exploded
and there's multiple traditions that we
can draw upon so it's it's it's
certainly not a
um
can i'm not trying to yeah anyway
in the interest of time well and
after jd and answer i think three
questions for a year but um i would also
just ask adam last question to both of
you
um on the theme of ai and humanity and
we're very much interested as
a group we're interested in how ai how
humanities are represented in a.i
are captured in ai and i think
jd i'm very curious what you think llm
whether llm brings anything
categorically different in terms of how
we think about humanity and for chris
i'm curious
how ai weather you believe ai would add
anything categorically different for
your work so maybe we don't have any uh
time for all of these but um i would
love to just throw out there if you have
anything to share sure i mean i think so
um
the question sort of of of culpability
and responsibility i think perhaps those
mean slightly different things this come
up a bunch of times
and and you actually chris you asked the
question of like well if not the human
the loop then who who is responsible and
i think
you know
i haven't really heard that much talk
about the system designers except in the
anecdote that you gave that i wasn't
familiar with about the uh what was it
what did you call it the robot robot
death was it in australia that the
changes
yeah
yeah
what was that there may be a very
different kind of chat what was the
actual name i'm sorry
the uh well i can't the actual name was
much less um
you know if they called it robert from
the beginning people might have been
more suspicious you know
fair enough fair enough but i think the
automated debt recovery algorithm i
think so that was okay
yeah yeah i think that you know maybe we
should be asking some questions of the
system designers if there's not a human
in the loop rather than
you know treating the human in the loop
as sort of the end of
the chain of humans involved in that oh
certainly i don't know
in the settlement decision yeah
there was an explicit
judicial decision
that none of the designers had a
culpable mental state none of them
knew
adequately that this was incorrect and
gonna cause harm
[Music]
in a way that would generate a legal
liability or just kind of a striking
environment of the capabilities of
policy
not quite right
no
you know it's hard in 15 minutes but i
have to
fundamentally
reiterate that i'm not critiquing the
idea that you should blame the human
operator and ignore the designer and
ignore policy you know the question is
the kind of like openness of what that
means by capability and probability and
in terms of political agency
um
um the question i mean
in terms of what like ai um
i mean
it does so much obviously these systems
are so different compared to the kind of
industrial systems
at three mile island i think an
interesting one
which i don't know enough about to
really comment upon in any kind of uh
intelligent way but the functions of
sort of back propagation and forward
propagation
in in in
in in machine learning
that's sort of interesting to me as a
way of maybe trying to automate this
afterwardsness you know back and
forthness
but i think uh
but i think there's still a
it's interest there's a different kind
of way of error involved here again in
terms of magnitude as opposed to kind of
um
the way humans are wrong about things
which i also think has a lot to do with
love or at least with desire or the lack
of desire
um
you know it's different you know
fair enough yeah
the one thing maybe i'll add in the
remaining 15 seconds here is is um there
are a number of questions i think uh um
tom you asked a question about sort of
dolly and like where does that sit into
these kinds of questions and i think i'm
sorry i can't read your name
was asking a little bit about um and
telling you you were also about like you
know who
does it actually is there is the human
that is involved in that process of the
same level of
um
impact or effort of ownership or
ownership over that part of the process
like is it really that person's work if
uh if in fact it was in part generated
by some other system and their role was
more curatorial than than generative i
mean i think these are all these are all
great questions and chen you are asking
also about whether or not
whether or not large language models
sort of bring humanity into the ai
world and i don't know that there are
answers to these questions because i
think in in large part it depends on how
you define these things and
in many cases we define ai and humanity
in in weird exclusive ways and it's not
at all clear to me that they are
exclusive right like large language
models do incorporate the writings of
billions if not you know
hundreds of millions certainly of people
if not billions of of things that
they've said online right and that are
now sort of
accumulated in some relatively unknown
way uh into
a system that reproduces things that
kind of look like what those people said
and so
it's not clear that you can actually
draw
such a
such an obvious bright line between that
system and and the people whose data
went into it
i'm going to let you go that easily with
those three questions about i think
the sort of unintended consequences of
llm so we mentioned like offensive meme
generation
sort of automating personal writing and
then there's a grammarly question do you
want to comment on that and i think
there is and i also want to point out i
think there is a very interesting
dynamic here where chris was critiquing
the afterwardness
of
the workers well as i unfortunately
you're the worker in this case
you are trying to predict some of the
second order effect effects before these
llms are
already ubiquitous so i wonder how
i'm sure there are a lot of the part of
the question cannot be answered because
we don't quite know but like
do you want to comment on the part like
which part might be answerable
yeah it's a good question i mean so i
think conor to your question about
grammarly you know there's this there's
this uh i think
there's an interesting question about
the use of those kinds of systems and
what they really mean right like you
could have made the same argument about
spell checkers like you know are people
who use spell checkers like are they
really
you don't think so i mean so
well maybe we can chat about that
distinction later i i think there is an
open question about whether or not the
like maybe this is what you were asking
like are the things that are produced
with the help of grammarly then being
fed back into the same training models
that are then being produced sort of as
though they were correct but in fact
they're just sort of echoes of previous
corrections of the existing text
yeah it's a different loop totally right
it's a loop that's now intermediated
behind some other system that thinks
this is correct rather than some actual
human judgment yeah
um i think it's a really interesting
question i don't think i have an answer
to it sorry
um
i you know i think there are there are
explicit attempts to address those kinds
of questions like um
i forget if it was gbtv or some other
language language model that explicitly
said you know our training data ends
here
and
you know please include
this token in your
website if you are using text that was
generated by gbt3 so that we know not to
include it in future training sets um so
i think this concern exists among the
folks who are working in this domain but
i you know i suspect
i mean even if they do you know i
suspect that most don't right even if
some do
just because it is you know you to the
extent that the llm is is even doing the
entirety of the generation if there's
like a human curator and choosing
different words etc like where do you
draw the line of whether it was
generated or not
yeah
great ending on this upbeat note
thank you everyone we have a short
coffee break i think and we'll come back
in 25 minutes for
the next session
oh 15.
okay
the boss has spoken
yes
[Music]
outside
[Applause]
is